oh hi how are you guys today welcome
back to my Stephen King series today
we're going to be talking about the
Shawshank Redemption there are a billion
reviews praising the Shawshank
Redemption everybody loves it I love it
I didn't just want to make another video
talking about how great this movie is so
I thought why not go to where they
actually shot the movie this is the Ohio
State Reformatory it's about an hour
away for my house believe it or not and
we're going to be talking about the
Shawshank Redemption today where they
actually film it
[Music]
welcome to the warden's office this is
the actual office where they shot all of
the warden scenes that he had that guy
would be embodiment of evil played
marvelously by Bob Gunton every single
time I think of the creepiest movie
villains or the ones that did the most
despicable thing I think of this guy
just sitting in this chair makes me feel
more people looking out the window where
he blew the back of his skull open
and right here is the safe or Andy
Dufresne kept all of the wardens tax
documents and also the script for the
last Jedi so you go on I mean stamp your
forum stop wasting my time tell you the
truth I don't give a this is the
parole room where the character of red
played by Morgan Freeman goes three
times to try to get the role it's three
of my favorite scenes in the whole movie
it's a brilliant art for his character
with each parole scene that accompanies
each act you get to see the progression
of his character I think it's more tired
as the film goes along and as he
continues to age in Shawshank Prison
finally culminating in my favorite scene
in the entire film where he explains
where he has no idea what rehabilitated
actually means he says it's just a
made-up word so people like you can wear
a suit and tie have a job it's my
favorite scene in the entire film this
was Brookes room one of the best
characters in the movie the type of
character that a lot of people I think
if they were making this movie today
would delete a Sunni would probably say
we don't need that Brookes character
he's like this side character he doesn't
matter but he's one of the most
important ones in the story his
inclusion in the film is so important
because it shows how institutionalized
someone can be how the actual prison
that they're staying in becomes their
home and when he's eventually released
the real world the place that he was
hoping to go to all those years becomes
the prison it's something to think about
that and it needs to one of the better
scenes in the film where rez captor
talks about what it's like to be
institutionalized how when you first
arrive in prison you hate the walls but
then you get used to them and eventually
you depend on them
City Stories the prison cells men rotted
their lives way in here I wonder if any
of them are still around how do you
think Matt thank are there the other
there you guys have a nice night stay
away from me you get have a nice night
welcome to the showers of Shawshank
Prison this is where Andy was almost
brutally violated by the sisters since
this was at one point in time a
real-life prison odds are that has
occurred in this room before so out of
all the places in this prison I'm
assuming this is probably the most
haunted because I imagine all of the
most haunting experience has occurred
here so we should probably leave this
area now I would say otherwise the
ghosts of the sisters might show up and
we don't want that well there's a
solitary confinement this is where Tim
Robbins spent two months straight
thinking about how terribly was
according to the warden this is where
the warden looked down upon it and my
cameraman is in solitary confine right
now this is the actual movie prop of
Andy's tunnel that he dug out and sell
when the warden discovers that he rips
the Rita Hayworth poster out and we get
that amazing shot of a dolly out of the
tunnel and they've actually kept this
entire prop here restored for anybody to
come and look I don't know if I could
actually crawl through this
I guess it just comes down to one simple
truth Matt just busy livin
get busy doing
yeah damn right guys thank you so much
for watching this review of the
Shawshank Redemption
it was amazing to be able to film and
the Mansfield reformatory here thank you
so much to Matt for helping me film this
please subscribe to his channel and
thank you to Dan Smith the creative
director here for letting us film here
so nice of you man it was seriously like
a dream come true to do this and being
able to share this with my subscribers
it's also just a great feeling and if
you guys want to take tours here you can
I'm putting a link in the description
below they did not ask me to do that the
Saints sponsored this is entirely just
because they're amazing so it's super
cheap the tour here if you're in the
area definitely come check it out guys
thank you so much for watching my
Stephen King series you're the best if
you liked this you can click right here
it's Tuchman eyes
[Music]
you